so let's start with something simple
okay because i think this is like a
reasonable entry point some of you have
never heard of him if you don't know who
he is he's a kickboxing champion lives
in romania um runs a bunch of businesses
does well for himself he's funny as hell
like i see him more as a comic if
you don't think he has a sense of humor
then you need to go watch his interview
or um when he was on the podcast with
tom segura who's a stand-up comic i mean
he's the buddy of joe rogans i've seen a
bunch of his stand-ups i think tom
segura is hilarious and his wife pointed
out even when he was on that podcast
that she's never seen world-class comics
make this guy laugh the way that tate
did i think he's hilarious a lot of the
stuff that he says um
is built in character
um i've seen a break character from time
to time but i think for the most part
what he says he truly believes in
although you know some of it is
manufactured for some of the stuff that
he's doing right yeah it's uh yeah it's
called the your mom's house podcast
anyway so let's play this first one here
another thing that a lot of people make
a mistake with when i talk to them like
ah i have to go to work today change
your language i get to go to work today
imagine you had no job be worse right so
you get to go to work i have to fix the
car
at least you have a car most people
don't bought one i have to go get the
kids you get to go get the kids because
you have these beautiful children who
love you people's even their own
language is wrong maybe i'm completely
crazy maybe i'm full of [ __ ] but the
frames i've installed in my mind are all
beneficial to me but that makes me crazy
and full of [ __ ] good because i can't
become depressed there's another thing
that so
yeah so he gets criticized for um saying
things like depression isn't real and
i've got a clip here where he talks
about a little bit more and we'll dive
into that but
i kind of place this one front and
center because you kind of have to ease
into some of the dialogue and sort of
conversations that he has uh you know
not not jump into it too harshly right
away if you know what i'm saying but
all he's really do doing is he's saying
you know change your mindset you know
like if you believe the cap like the cup
is half full you're gonna have a better
attitude on life than looking at
everything you know pessimistically
there's loads of people out there right
now today in the world that love playing
the victim card it's like oh poor me
you know i can never catch a break blah
blah blah and it's like
avoid those people right if you can't
view the world through a lens uh of
optimism at the very least like i'm not
saying rose colored lens and like you
know you know pretend anything's
rainbows and butterflies because it
ain't you know [ __ ] ain't really like
easy out there but at least you know
change your mindset you know to the
point where it's like you know you look
at the world through
a glass half full sort of lens and
you're gonna have a better experience
operating and is really all that he's
saying in this clip over here so let's
pull this out
and uh let's drop in the next one here
uh what do we have on this one
okay so this is a clip that he did with
um
dave portnoy i think is his name from uh
uh what's what's the show called uh
barstool sports or something like that
we're it's a strange podcast because it
has like very little to do with talking
about sports but
it's actually pretty funny um so let's
throw this one up and throw this clip
where he's talking about
um he's not sexist but he's a realist
so here we go
i hate women i i mean we can attempt to
label me without all we want i'm happy
to discuss it i have this impression i
hate women i i mean we can attempt to
label me without all we want i'm happy
to discuss her i absolutely not really
love her i have nothing against women i
believe women are the most precious
things on the planet they create life
they should be protected they should
provide it for i would never let a woman
pay for a bill if someone touched me to
my woman i would stand up against 10 men
by myself and risk my life to protect
her i believe that women are beautiful
creatures i just don't think that
they're as emotionally calm as men in
stressful situations i don't think they
can fight like a man can and for the
same reason i would never drop my
children in an all-male nursery i think
that's strange and weird i would only
drop them in an all-female nursery women
do certain things and men do certain
things and we live in a world now where
the whole idea of the roles has been
conflated to the fact where if i come
along and say women are better with
children men are better at fighting but
i'm somehow [ __ ] sexist when it's
clearly true there's nothing wrong with
stating the facts i don't yeah so
in this clip he's he's stating facts
right you know like i
why would you drop off your kid at a
nursery that would be run by dudes like
he's right like that like that would
feel weird you know the same the same
way that even as a father
to a kid if you're if you're doing
something you know parenting wise with a
small child let's say a three-year-old
or something like that um
other parents especially moms they
they're they're very protective of their
kids and they don't want like you know
an adult male even even if they're a
father with a small child around clearly
that's theirs around their kid alone um
that's just how you know society
operates but we can't say thing and one
of the points that he was making in this
clip and it didn't show up in that clip
i don't think was um they were talking
about female pilots
and at some point he said something
along the lines of you know if i see a
female pilot on a plane like um i'm
basically not happy i'd rather have a
male pilot because they deal better in
stressful rational situations
and
what's what's wrong with that you know
another argument that was tied into that
i think was
women uh
aren't
as great behind uh the wheel of a car is
what a guy is
and i made this argument it's like every
single check they've ever dated has
always had
scratches dings dents in their car
bumpers hanging off a little bit
whatever you know they back into
something they don't see it whatever
whatever like this is this is how women
drive it's like
but then people argue and say well why
do they have lower insurance rates well
probably because they're not claiming
the damage that's still on their car
because of the deductible and it's too
much and they just leave it on the car
because it doesn't matter right they're
not like guys where guys
take pride in ownership in a vehicle car
guys anyway you know if they have a nice
car they take pride in ownership
vehicles with a scratch or a ding or
something happens it's fixed
automatically i remember this lady
backed up
on a ramp on the hood of my r8 if you
guys have followed my channel for a
while you know that i had a it was a
2011 uh v10 manual beautiful spider
lady backed up to it on a ramp and put a
little dent just above the emblem
and i was furious man uh but it had to
get fixed um cost 26 thousand dollars
for the insurance company to fix a
little dent just above the emblem on an
r8 but they you know repaint everything
they got to change the hinges the
latches uh clips and everything you know
part of the headlight bezel just minor
minor stuff but it like it got done and
i paid the thousand dollar deductible
because i wouldn't drive around in a
nice car with a dent in it but women all
the time and you know you could argue
with me all you want you know it's true
women all the time will drive around in
a car it's got dense dings you know
bumper damage stuff like that just
because they don't really care right um
well yeah like it is what it is but
in a stressful situation
women generally don't have it as
together as a guy does just just being
honest right i mean they'll they'll
freak out you know like
i've been camping right um
i used to do work when i was 16 up in
northern ontario for the ministry of
natural resources one summer and
if there was any women remotely around
things like a bear or some like random
animal or something they'd freak out
like like they'd have like a meltdown of
spaz whereas guys just like yeah
whatever you know this is what you do
put your hands up look big blah blah
walk away sort of thing it's like you
know you're at the bear dump you just
kind of like make your way out
but
they're not as rational as guys are so
that's really the argument that he's
awake making he's basically saying you
know i'm not sexist for saying these
things i'm just saying you know facts
that i'm observing which i agree with i
mean i don't see anything wrong with
that he's it's it's just being like you
know real to the point
is what it is hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha
you'll get 10 off on your first order
there's also the option to use the
subscribe and save model where regular
shipments will be sent over to you on a
regular basis and that gives you a
little bit of a discount and your
supplement facts are always broken down
over here thanks for watching i hope you
guys have an awesome day and again check
out that link it's pinned in the top
comment below in this video peace out
you